There are plenty of
other sort of threats.
Social media, whatever you choose to
make public, people can learn a lot
about you, including who your
friends are and things like that.
Tracking of web browsing, what sites
you visit, actually it's usable.
The sites I choose to visit obviously
know about I visiting those websites.
But the third parties that
actually can record or
track the fact that you visited
the New York Times for example,
or you visited Facebook,
or whatever it is.
There are a lot of location aware
applications that know where you
are all the time.
Again, the example of someone seeing
that you're in a certain location sort
of randomly is very different than
being able to do it constantly.
And sometimes we are the enablers for
this sort of tracking that could happen,
so we are the willing party.
For example,
if you use loyalty cards for
a little discount in your grocery store,
of course they're able to track you.
They know that you visited them, they
know what kind of things you bought,
because they're able to tie
your multiple register use of
this loyalty card that
we're talking about.